MALE SPEAKER: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I hosted this talk-- I
initially was introduced
to Clarity Media when
I was interviewing.
As many of you know that
the Google interview process
can be a little challenging,
especially from the outside.
And it's even weirder when
you see it from the inside.
So I worked with Clarity
Media to become more effective
in interviews and
learned how to prepare
to be more effective
in general in speaking.
And I was able to take the
things I learned from them
and apply them to
wedding speeches I gave,
to be more effective
in meetings.
Even one of the
wedding speeches I gave
was actually in Japanese,
and I don't speak Japanese.
So there's a lot of
really incredible stuff.
So hopefully it's really
useful to everyone.
And a pleasure to
introduce Bill McGowan.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL McGOWAN: Thank you.
I had no idea we specialized
in bilingual wedding toasts.
That's actually even
a surprise to me.
I appreciate everybody coming.
And presumably, everybody
here or watching
is here because you'd
like to be better
at public speaking or
external communication.
So I want to give you
a bunch of tips today
that I think would
up everybody's game.
Right off the bat,
just about every year
some kind of
publication comes out
with a list of what the
biggest fears in our life are.
And every year, the list
stays pretty much the same.
Our fear of our own mortality
is usually at number one,
getting on a plane
is number three,
and I'm sure it comes as no
surprise to everybody what
the number two fear is.
Everybody knows that it's
public speaking, right?
And there are a
number reasons why
this can throw us and send
us into angst before we
have to get up and present.
Most of the people
we work with are
on the left side
of this spectrum.
They either have a
fear of doing it,
or they can tolerate it
if they're asked to do it.
They're on a team and
it's their responsibility.
But very few people actually
get a buzz from doing it.
And what we tend to do is try
to get people from apprehension
to being OK with it.
And the encouraging news is once
you get to being OK with it,
there is a way to
actually get to the point
where you enjoy it.
And that's really
the sweet spot,
because the more you enjoy it,
the more you'll raise your hand
and volunteer to do it.
And the more you do it, the
better you'll get at it.
So my key advice would be
embrace every opportunity
to get up and talk when
somebody on your team
suggests you do it.
Or don't shy away from an
opportunity to public speak.
It's the best way
to get better at it.
The one thing you
should definitely
stay away from
though is winging it.
And I find this
is not a strategy.
Thinking that magic fairy
dust is going to sprinkle down
on you and you're going to be
eloquent and articulate and
effective and persuasive in the
moment is really not realistic.
And this isn't just about
giving a keynote speech
or giving a presentation.
This about heading into a
meeting where you may think,
I'm probably going to be a
spectator in this meeting
and I'm very likely not going
to be asked for my input.
You can't assume that.
You should even
go into a meeting
that you think you're going to
be a spectator at with an idea
of what am I going to say if
somebody wheels around asks me
for my opinion on this subject.
Let me plan what my point of
view is and make it succinct.
Sometimes we work with very
accomplished, grade A speakers.
And we'll be in a
private session with them
and we'll be role playing,
we'll be videotaping them.
And their energy level
is not that great,
and I'll tell them I think
you need to bump this up.
You're sort of
mailing it in here.
And oftentimes what we'll hear
from a client is don't worry,
when the adrenaline is going
and I'm doing the real thing,
everything's going to be fine.
I'll be great.
And my urging to them
was about practicing
the same way you play for
real often fell on deaf ears
until the first presidential
debate of the last election
cycle.
And if anybody has read
the dissection of what
happened there, the present
went out to Las Vegas
and he set up debate camp.
And he was handed
videotapes of Mitt Romney
and his primary
debates, and he was
asked to take a look at them.
Next thing you know, he
was off at Hoover Dam
shaking hands and
doing some photo ops
and he's just not engaged.
And David Axelrod, his chief
adviser, came up to him
and he said Mr. President,
we're a little concerned.
You don't seem plugged in.
You don't seem like
you're investing the time.
And the president's
response to Axelrod
was very much what
I hear from people
who realize that they have a
tremendous aptitude for this.
So my point is if that guy
can't magically flip a switch
and be great because he
has short changed the prep,
there's actually very little
hope for the rest of us.
Same thing with Bill Clinton.
Somebody very close to
him said best communicator
I've ever known, I've
ever worked with,
when he was prepared.
But when he wasn't and all
hell was breaking loose
and we were crashing in the limo
on the way over to an event,
it always showed up.
So don't think that
there is an elite crew
of gifted communicators
who can just
mail it in and be
spontaneous and great.
It actually doesn't happen.
And when you're rehearsing,
when you're practicing a speech
or presentation-- which you
absolutely should do-- the four
words you should never say is
let's just start this again.
When you make a mistake in
rehearsal, don't give up.
The important thing
is to teach yourself
how you pull out of a moment
where you're having brain lock
or you've lost your transition,
or something's gone wrong.
If you don't practice
that in rehearsal,
you'll never know how
to do it when you get up
and give the speech for real.
It would be almost like
a pilot in training
going into a flight
simulator and then
just giving totally
normal conditions,
never making them fly
through turbulence
or learn how to navigate
the plane in trouble.
So try to force yourself
through those rough patches
when you're rehearsing.
How many of you here
battle with this?
Feel anxious and you get a
little sick to your stomach?
It is a perfectly natural
byproduct of public speaking,
and it's what usually
keeps us from doing it.
The very simple equation is
the more you're prepared,
the less anxious
you're going to be.
It happens every single time.
And you're probably going to be
most nervous in the first two
minutes of a presentation.
Until you get your feet under
you and you relax into it.
So really know that opening
backwards and forwards.
And I mean the first line
of what you're going to say.
Don't leave the first 15, 20
second warm up to ad libbing.
Even know that.
Whenever you hear
somebody at a podium who
has that little shake, that
little tremble in their voice
which is a dead giveaway
that they're nervous,
those are a product of nerves.
But it's also a result of
not breathing properly.
And when we get really nervous,
we start mini hyperventilating.
These short shallow breaths
which actually winds up
depleting our lungs
of air, and that's
what gives the
shake to our voice.
So if you find your pulse
is running away with you
and you're extremely nervous,
find a nice quiet place
down the hallway
before you go on.
Three or four deep yoga breaths,
long intake through your nose.
Hold it.
Long, slow, steady exhale
through your mouth.
It's going to slow
your pulse, it's
going to replenish
your lungs with air,
and it's going to bring
stability back your voice.
Because you don't want
to be up at the podium
and looking like you're a wreck.
But even if you don't
battle real anxiety,
we all get a shot of adrenaline
when we get up to speak.
And that can have a good result
and it can have a bad result.
You're probably going to talk
a lot faster in the first five
minutes from just
being a little anxious.
So make sure you
come out of the gate
in a nice, controlled pace.
Your eye movement is going to
accelerate the more nervous
you are.
So right now, I'm communicating
directly with you.
And I'm going to
move off and connect
with somebody else in the room.
That is ultimately
what you're after.
What you don't
want to do is what
I'm doing right now,
which is actually
ping ponging around
the room and not
landing on anybody specific.
I'm looking at all of these
heads as an abstraction,
or I'm drifting over the
tops of people's heads.
And it doesn't have the
same level of connection
that landing on
people actually does.
And we have all this
pent up physical energy
from this shot of adrenaline.
And our bodies like
to get rid of it.
And our feet typically wind up
being the portal through which
we like to expunge this energy.
So many times, you'll
see people in front
of a room doing what I
call the stationary march.
Which is, I'm not
really moving anywhere,
but I'm also not standing still.
There's a lot a rocking,
there's a lot of swaying.
And I see this all the time.
It just gives a fidgety,
nervous appearance
to your presentation.
To avoid that, you want to stand
with you weight a little bit
forward on the
balls of your feet.
You should feel a little bit
of pressure in your toes.
What that does is it
keeps you off your heels
where you wind up swaying
and rocking the most.
The only place you
want to be leaning
is actually into the audience
to connect with them.
And I'm going to show you
a clip of Reed Hastings who
commits this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BILL McGOWAN: Reed's feet
actually never planted
that entire time.
They were in constant
motion, and it's
only because his body
is trying to get rid
of that excess physical energy.
It looks a little antsy.
And you should probably
stay away from it.
Good news is all
that nagging we got
as children was
absolutely right.
Don't stay up until 3 o'clock
in the morning working
on a presentation you
have to do at 9 AM.
You'd be better off going to
bed early, getting up at four,
and finishing it.
You're going to be
a lot more alert.
And never do anything--
public speaking,
presentation on
an empty stomach.
It's been proven medically
that the synapses in your brain
do not fire as
efficiently if you
don't have fuel in your body.
We just talked a little
bit about making sure
that you're not slumped.
And if you're tall-- anybody
really tall in this room?
Don't be apologetic
about your height.
There's a lot of times
I see people just trying
to compensate for their height.
Totally own your height
in the front of a room.
And we talked a little
bit about that connection.
This is even true across
a conference table
when you're having a meeting.
The fact of the matter
is we can concentrate
on what we say a lot better if
we're looking into abstraction.
Looking at the
pattern in this rug
gives me a lot more
privacy to think
about what I want to say
than looking directly
into your eyes.
It doesn't have the same
level of connection.
And if anybody saw the
piece in the New York Times
this Sunday in the
week in review,
there's an amazing piece
in there about eye contact
and how incredibly
important it is
to the signals you send to
the person you're talking to.
So if you find looking
at the person you're
talking to too unsettling, it
doesn't give you that privacy
to think, then move your
focus off just slightly.
Like you could look at
the stem of my glasses,
or you could look at
a woman's earring.
Keep it in this general range.
No one is going to know that
you're just slightly off.
And it gives you something
small and private zone
in on that doesn't
make the invasiveness
of the other person's stare
back at you unsettling at all.
And I find that
sometimes we're so
concentrating on
being technically good
and not making any
mistakes or stumbling
through a presentation
or a speech
that we wind up flattening out.
Your focus really
shouldn't be getting
through the thing
technically perfect.
That should not be your
definition of success.
Your definition of success
is showing a real palpable
enthusiasm for the
value of the information
you're sharing
with other people.
If you don't lead
by example, they're
not going to think it
matters and they're
going to start tuning you out.
And there are a few things
our mothers did not tell us.
If you want to avoid developing
a frog in your throat
where you have to
[CLEARS THROAT] every two
minutes be clearing your throat,
stay away from cheese, yogurt,
milk that morning.
It creates congestion
and wind up--
people smiling, absolutely true.
Make sure you get to
the room ahead of time.
If it's a stage where
you're presenting,
you don't want to be up on that
stage in a strange environment
when you're doing it for real.
Try to get in the night
before and check out
what the audience looks like
and have it be familiar to you.
Also make sure all
of your tech is
in place-- batteries
on a clicker.
My assistant back
in New York got
me the best holiday gift ever.
She got me a pair of cuff-links
that actually come apart
and it's a USB drive.
And believe it or
not, I actually
download my presentations
on this cuff-link.
Because I've had a couple of
occasions where the file got
corrupted that I emailed
to the place ahead of time,
and I've had to pull that thing
out and actually work from it.
And it just happened
this afternoon.
I've coached a bunch of
people here a year or so ago,
and so I have permission
to be on the Google Guest
wireless network.
And I don't have
to click a thing.
It just automatically kicks in.
I learned the hard way
that you should always
turn your wireless off.
At another presentation,
at a client
that I arrived at on
a subsequent visit,
I didn't do it.
And I'm merrily clicking
along, and in the middle
of slide four or five, all
of my email notifications
from the night before
start bonging up
in the corner of the screen.
Which was not exactly what
you want to have happen.
So turn your wireless off.
Quit all programs
that could wind up
sending you a notification
in the middle.
When I say work the
room, I mean see
if you can say hello
to people beforehand.
Or maybe you're at an
off-site and there's
a coffee urn and some
snacks in a separate room.
See if you can get around
say hello to people.
And just a series of 60,
90 second conversations.
It's going to accomplish a
number of things for you.
One, it's going to keep you from
huddling away and obsessively
worrying about the presentation
you're about to do.
It'd be better to get
your mind off of it.
You've probably done all
the prep you need to do.
And in talking to people,
oftentimes they'll
tell you something
that you can work with.
Or somebody tells you a
story at the coffee urn
and you realize, you know, that
would actually be a great thing
to insert in the presentation.
A little quick
story, because it's
so interwoven with the whole
point of my presentation.
That can be a great way to
give a feeling of spontaneity
to your presentation,
to actually reference it
in your speech.
And it also brings the
audience up with you
a little bit closer.
It also helps you understand
is this a tough crowd,
is this an easy crowd?
How hard am I going to have to
work to keep their engagement?
And ultimately, if I have
a conversation with you
over the coffee, I'm no
longer a stranger to you.
And so you're going to be a
lot more likely to be invested
in listening to me closely.
If you and I talked
beforehand, I
guarantee you're not going
to take your phone out.
You're going to feel too
bad that somehow I'll
feel slighted.
So what it also
does is it sets up
people in various
areas of the room
to bolster your confidence.
And think about your room
as broken into quadrants.
So I have near right, far
right, far left, near left.
And what I want to do is find
four people in the room who
are good, enthusiastic listeners
who are smiling and nodding
and helping me realize,
OK, this is coming through.
They're engaged.
And if you get freaked out by
talking to a hundred people
or more, make this a
conversation with four people.
And I guarantee you
nobody in the audience
is going to know
that you're basically
talking to four people.
What you don't
want to do is catch
the eye of the person
who now is doing that.
That is going to be an
absolute confidence killer.
So while you want to be
able to read the room,
I often tell people
don't over read the room.
You may very well find a crowd
where the faces are blank
and you're getting nothing
back from them whatsoever.
Don't let that little
voice on your shoulder
convince you that this
is going terribly.
Because many, many times
I've had the most checked
out looking person
in the audience
come up to me
afterwards and say,
I found what you
said so fascinating.
Can you tell me a little
bit more about that?
And my initial
reaction was, wow,
you looked absolutely
on another planet.
I cannot believe you're
the person coming up to me
afterwards and
asking me for more.
So don't let those
blank faces throw you.
You need to warm up.
Athletes do it.
Singers do it.
And there's a big
fundamental difference
between silently imagining
in your head what you're
going to say and in your kitchen
that morning making coffee,
saying the first two
minutes out loud.
It's a very
different experience.
And when you hear
yourself, you're
going to be better able to
edit yourself and make changes
if it doesn't feel
right that day.
So I think getting
started is always
a very difficult
thing for people.
How do you grip people right
from the very beginning?
One thing I want to
make sure you never do
is have sentences that have
inherent apology behind them.
And I've heard just about
every time slot of the day,
whether you're 8:30 in the
morning, 11:30 in the morning,
two in the afternoon, or
4:30, apologize for the time.
So listen, I know
it's really early.
It's 8:30.
Everybody's kind of
groggy from last night.
But I'm just going to
very quickly walk you
through some things.
That in and of itself says I
know you don't want to be here.
I know you're being
made to be here.
But don't worry, I won't
be belabor the point.
Don't do that.
Or at 4:30, don't
say, listen, I know
I'm the only thing standing
between you and the cocktail
hour.
Uh-uh.
That is not what you're doing.
You're trying to
present an image where
I know you're going to
find this interesting.
I know this is going
to be valuable to you.
That's what you want
to be protecting.
Also, I know we've been
ingrained to think, tell them
what you're going to tell
them, tell them, and tell them
what you told them.
It is such a dusty, outdated
method of presenting.
And everybody does it.
And my advice to you is don't
sound like everybody else.
Because when you hit
this conformity zone
of your structure and your words
sounding like everybody else's,
that's when your
audience tunes out.
Try to find a different
way of starting.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
And then there
are the people who
get up and do the
table of contents.
All right.
So I'm Bill McGowan.
I'm from Clarity Media Group.
I'm going to talk a little
today about public speaking.
First of all, don't
ever talk about what
you're going to talk about.
That's the biggest
waste of language ever.
And don't say so now I want to
share with you a little story.
Don't.
Just go right into the story.
Don't constantly play traffic
cop and flag me on what
you're about to do.
If you took all of those
things out of a presentation,
I guarantee you'd be two
minutes later right off the bat
without losing any content.
So in the book, I take
the agenda setting starter
and I realized it was a
very apropos acronym here.
Try to see if you
can avoid that.
So my new favorite speaker is
a guy named Geoffrey Canada.
I don't know if any
of you know him.
He's an education expert.
And I want to show
you a clip of what
I think is just an outstanding
way to start a presentation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm a little nervous because
my wife, Yvonne, said to me,
she said Geoffrey, you
watch the Ted Talks?
I said, yes, honey,
I love Ted Talks.
She said, you know
they're really smart,
talented-- I said,
I know, I know.
She said, they don't
want the angry black man.
So I said no, I'm
going to be good honey,
I'm going to be good.
I am.
But I am angry.
[LAUGHTER]
And the last time I looked--
[APPLAUSE]
So this is why I'm
excited, but I'm angry.
This year, there are going to
be millions of our children
that we're going
to needlessly lose.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BILL McGOWAN: So
the reason why I
think this is the
perfect beginning--
and I realize this is probably
a more theatrical setting
than what all of us
find ourselves in.
But the structure applies.
And that is he's not
starting off with a joke,
some random joke that
could bomb and throw
your confidence completely.
He's starting off with
a story that allows
you to feel like you have
access to a conversation he
and his wife had.
And the story has
humorous elements to it.
But the payoff to the story
is central to the theme
of what his overall talk is.
So the punch line
is that he's angry.
But the theme of
the talk is he's
disappointed and frustrated
with how little we've
moved the needle in
education in this country.
So there's a point to the story.
It's not just a random
drop-in to get a laugh.
And the laugh, of course,
probably relaxes him
and helps him on his way.
We focus a lot on just word
selection in what we do.
And we believe and agree with
all the great literary minds
and geniuses
throughout time that
adhered to this
idea of simplicity.
Don't over complicate something.
If a $0.10 word is
perfectly good to use,
don't use a $0.50 word and
make it more elaborate and more
wordy.
Simpler is better.
And I find that there's also a
lot of new word creation going
on.
Planful, choiceful, all
this ridiculous stuff I
hear coming out
of people's mouths
that if you were to write
it on your computer,
there would be a red line
underneath that word.
And if there's a red line
underneath that word,
that means it's not a word.
You shouldn't be saying it.
OK?
If your computer rejects
it, you should too.
And this stifling jargon
that just infects and invades
all the communication
that I hear going on,
the more you can jettison
that, the better.
And it affects
people at all levels.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Sometimes you
misunderestimated me.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
BILL McGOWAN: The
English language
gets butchered all over.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-They could refutiate what it
is that this group is saying--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BILL McGOWAN: And this
spot is 10 years old,
but still applicable.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What are you guys doing?
-We're ideating.
-id--what?
-Ideating.
-What's that?
-Coming up with new ideas.
-Why don't you
just call it that?
-This is different.
-We need to rethink
the way we do things.
-Structure.
-Process.
-We need to innovate.
-How?
-We haven't ideated that yet.
-Good luck.
-Thanks.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BILL McGOWAN: The reason
that spot is so funny
is it's so close to the truth.
It's barely an exaggeration.
So I'd like you to really
look through your content
and think not only can I strip
this down to make it simpler,
but how can I take some of the
stifling jargon out of the mix.
And it's one of the reasons
why I want to do this book
and share some of these ideas.
And I break them into
a number of principles
that I think are good to follow.
One of them is this
idea of brevity.
And in the book, I call this
the Pasta Sauce Principle.
I actually wanted to call
it the Puttanesca Principle,
but my agent worried that
not everybody cooks and not
everybody would know
what Puttanesca is.
Anyway, so we made it the
Pasta Sauce Principle.
And the premise is very simple.
When you have a pot on the stove
and you boil that thing down,
and you reduce it, that thing
has more dynamic flavor.
If you keep adding
more volume to it,
it basically tastes
very bland and it's
thoroughly forgettable.
So I'd like you to
think about talking
the way you think about cooking.
See if even in an email--
like go back and read an email
and think, could I take
20% out of this thing?
Probably easily, right?
See if you can contract
just about everything.
And when we speak, I
find that most people
are pretty good about getting
out of the gate of their idea
and getting to the crux of what
it is they want to talk about.
But then wrapping
the whole thing up
and getting to the finish
line gets sometimes
to be a little bit of a
messy journey in which we're
a lot less strategic,
a lot less planned,
there's a lot more ad libbing
and spontaneity involved.
And that's usually
where we wind up
just having excessive
length to the idea
we're trying to communicate.
And usually bad
things happen when
we're off the trail
and unplanned.
In fact, if you look at any of
the analyses of big PR blunders
by notable people,
you'll find that where
they made the mistake
was right about there.
Right before they finished
up when they were not
going according to what
they had planned to say.
So rather than thinking,
all right, well,
my answer to this
question should only
be 35 seconds or 40
seconds-- I don't
want you to think
in terms of time,
because everybody's a
little bit different.
But here's the
principal I'd like
you to see if you could follow.
By the time you open your
mouth to start talking,
I'd like you have a
general idea of what
the full arc of your thought is.
I'd like you have
a general sense
of what the finish
line looks like.
And I don't mean in terms of
a verbatim scripted answer
that you're now just reciting.
But I do think knowing
the components of what
goes into your
thought are important.
What's my point and how am I
going to illustrate that point?
How am I going to bring
it to life for people?
And that illustration can have
a number of different styles
to it.
It could be storytelling.
You could be citing
a specific example.
Or maybe there's
a compelling piece
of data that also
serves as a supporting
point to your main point.
And I find especially
in technology,
what I'm often working
with with clients
is you've just built something.
It solves a basic
problem for people.
And you're launching it.
I have to put out a
compelling narrative
as to why you should
download this thing.
So coming up with even
a hypothetical example
of how you'd use it and how
it would solve a basic problem
is an important thing to
think through ahead of time.
I find most people plan what
their point is and they leave
the illustration part of
their answer way too much,
they're just trying to
pull it out of thin air.
That should be as
well planned and well
thought out as your major point.
And if you can't
see the finish line
by the time you
start talking, that's
a clue you're talking too long.
See if you can get in the
habit of having control
over where you're ending
up with this idea.
Another principal in
the book is this notion
of thinking of
yourself as a movie
director in the front of a room.
And the fact of the
matter is all of us
are very visual creatures.
We all have this movie reel
spinning through our heads.
We crave images and we
play off them mentally.
And I in the front
of the room, I
need to be dictating what images
are spooling through your mind.
Because if I don't
do that, I don't
try to influence the
visual side of your brain,
your brain is going to go
off and make its own images.
And that's what's
called distraction.
That's daydreaming.
That's actually going to be
resulting in disengagement.
So see if you can maximize
the amount of time you speak
visually, anecdotally, and
limit the amount of time you're
speaking in a very
theoretical and abstract way.
You want a certain
balance there.
And the fact is that if we
embed information and facts
within a story,
it winds up being
22 times more likely to be
recalled and acted upon.
And also, images are
so much more memorable
than just facts or words.
So this notion of
story telling-- I
know we've heard it a
lot-- has been proven time
and again as being such
an important component
of your communication.
So what I would
really recommend is--
I'm sure you all have
these books you write in.
Realize that on a
daily or weekly basis,
things are happening to
us at work, when we're out
talking to maybe just
people who use the platform.
They say things or do things
that you realize, wow, actually
that would be a
great little story
to tell the next time I
have to present on this.
Jot it down.
Because I guarantee you if
you don't write it down,
you're going to forget it.
And the night before a
presentation is not the time
to be thinking, OK, do I
have any stories to tell?
Damn, what's been
going on lately?
You do not want to
be in that situation.
So start amassing these stories.
How many of you deal with
just filler language?
Yeah.
It's something we
all struggle with.
I have my own little
filler language
issue that I'm always
constantly thinking about,
I'm trying to work on.
And to get over this idea
of relying on filler,
I'd like you to
accept for a moment
this notion that your
brain and your mouth
are two cars on the road.
OK.
And your brain is the lead car.
It's always about a millisecond
ahead of your mouth.
It's figuring out
what conversational
road you're going to go
down and what words you're
going to use to
articulate that thought.
And then your
mouth follows along
once it gets instructions.
And we'd like to think that
when your brain comes up
to that intersection, it
makes those decisions very
efficiently.
But that's not the case.
Sometimes we get to the
juncture and we start pondering,
what word should I use?
Or maybe I shouldn't
tell this story.
And it creates this delay
in which your mouth now
needs to wait.
And while your mouth
is waiting, that's
typically where filler happens.
Filler language is what happens
when your mouth is waiting
for your brain to
come up with a plan.
So let's accept the fact
that we're not always
going to make these
decisions efficiently.
I want you to embrace this
principle that the less certain
you are about the
next idea coming out
of your mouth or the next
word you're going to use,
the slower you
should be talking.
What you should be doing
is building the equivalent
of a safe car length
distance between your mouth
and your brain.
The less certain you are,
the slower you should talk.
You should be building
in more pausing as well.
So many of us feel
uncomfortable with silence,
and that's why we go to
fill it with like, kind of,
sort of, you know, whatever.
It's the language
that absolutely
saps the appearance
of our professionalism
and our gravitas.
We don't want that
stuff creeping in.
Sort of and kind of is
a big one right now.
And I find that when especially
in tech companies where
you want to have a certain
humility to what you do,
we use those words
a lot because it
makes us sound less arrogant,
less opinionated, less certain.
And I just would advise
you not to overuse them.
Because I think it really
waters down your conviction
substantially.
OK.
So I like to typically end with
something everybody finds fun.
We didn't talk about
body language that much.
We talked a little
bit about standing,
but-- anybody want to take
a crack on the seven places
you shouldn't have
your hands when
you're standing in
front of a room?
[LAUGHTER]
Come on.
Let's go.
Who's got an idea?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Pockets.
BILL McGOWAN: Pockets.
Very good.
Next?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BILL McGOWAN: Very good.
OK.
So this is a good one.
Our saying is when your hands
drift above shoulder level,
nothing good is happening.
And that means that you're
either playing with your hair
to get it out of your eyes--
I had a guy the other day,
every 15 seconds
pulled his nose.
And he has no idea
he's doing this, right?
But there it goes,
every 15, 20 seconds.
Or you're scratching your ear or
you're playing with your beard.
No hands above shoulder level.
OK?
So pockets, shoulder level,
not behind your back.
Right?
Way too apologetic.
This has an I
totally don't deserve
to be up in front of
you, but I'm here anyway.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BILL McGOWAN: Good.
Very good.
Totally cuts the
audience off from you.
You're not nearly as accessible
to them as you should be.
So folded across the chest.
Not on your hips.
Not in your pockets.
We had that one.
This is the fig leaf, right?
It's too low.
This is praying.
That's too high.
So that's not in the mix either.
One of them is a little
counter intuitive,
and that is just dangling here.
I've never seen anybody
look comfortable
standing in front
of a room like this.
In fact, the weight of your
arms gives a little droop
your shoulders.
And you can look very slumpy.
So what I'd like you to do
is move from this position
and just create a right
angle with your upper arm
and your forearm.
And your hand should
come together right
around your belt buckle.
OK?
Not like you're ready
to kill somebody
with a very rigid
clasp, and nothing
shaped that's really obvious.
I just want your
hands very loosely
and relaxed overlapped right
around your belt buckle.
And the reason I
like this position
is I want to talk
with my hands, but I
don't want it to be a big
choreographed gesture that
winds up being the
center of attention.
I want it to be very
organic and natural.
So from here, they have
a very short distance
to kind of get in
the action-- See?
Kind of get in the action.
Not good.
They have a very
short distance to get
into the action and a very
short distance to rest.
Whereas down here when I go to
use them and I want to stop,
they've got a long way to fall.
In fact, a guy the other
day I was working with,
he went to stop and
his arms actually
swung from the
downward momentum.
So it may feel a little odd at
first, but it absolutely works.
And if you're giving
a presentation,
this can anchor your hands
in the right position.
Just hold onto your
clicker with two hands.
In terms of gesticulation,
don't over think it.
The only things you
want to stay away from
are repetitive
motions where I'm sort
of doing the same
thing all the time,
and now this starts
to get really
distracting and annoying.
And you see politicians do that.
They do the air
punch all the time.
And I wind up stopping
listening to what they're saying
and I start timing the
intervals of-- and I realize,
OK, I'm not listening
to this guy anymore.
Or anything really manic where
I'm just in constant motion
and I'm not stopping, and
the hands are never resting.
Realize that your hands have the
ability to bold and underline
an important thing
you want to say.
If they're moving all
the time, then you're
punching everything
and nothing stands out.
So realize if I'm
giving a presentation
and I'm coming up
to a big idea, there
are a number things I can do to
put that big idea on a pedestal
and have it be more noticed.
One is I can use my hands.
But I also want to
manipulate my voice
to change up the sound of how
it's coming at the audience.
Two good ways to do that are
to slow down and pull back.
You don't actually want to
punch your big idea louder.
See if you can pull
back on your volume
and keep up your intensity
to make the audience come in
and listen to you a
little bit more closely.
It's a really effective
tool, and it's
a little bit counter-intuitive.
I usually see people hammer that
thing like harder and louder.
That's not always
the best way to go.
So I'm more than
happy to address
any questions anybody may have.
I often say to
people too, if you're
going to take questions
after a presentation,
it always good to come with what
I call your own first question.
And that's because the most
awkward part of a presentation
is when you stand
up and say, OK,
so anybody have any questions?
Chirp, chirp.
Nobody wants to go first,
nobody's raising their hand.
And you don't want
to end on that note.
So always come
equipped with something
and say, typically when I give
this presentation, what people
are most curious
to know is how much
rehearsing is too
much rehearsing.
Just come with your
own thing to kick start
the Q&A. Because a
lot of times, nobody
wants to be the first
one raising their hand.
Or what you say could trigger
an idea somebody else has.
AUDIENCE: A number of years ago,
I think it was on Public Radio,
I heard about a study where they
were looking at speeches given
by CEOs of dot coms I think.
And they found an
inverse correlation
between how much of the
time they were lying
and how often they said um.
So the ones who didn't say um
at all were lying a lot more.
And I was wondering
if you'd heard of that
and what you think
is going on there.
BILL McGOWAN: I think there is
a desire for a lot of people
to try to create
a thoughtfulness
and a spontaneity
around something
that's very well rehearsed.
So I think what
you may be finding
or what that study
may be finding
is if they have some talking
point that's been scripted
and approved by the lawyers
and the communications people,
somebody training them may
say don't blurt this out
like it's a rehearsed,
memorized thing.
Bring some sort of feigned
hesitance to this idea.
Like, so, um, yeah,
I think-- I think
what we did here was
the right thing to do.
Even though on paper, that says
what we did the right thing.
Anyone who's been
coached tries to create
the feel of spontaneity.
But if they're at
a very high level,
I guarantee you that's been
removed from the equation
if they know what they're doing.
So it may be a
completely planned thing
to make it sound like this
isn't our message point here,
this is actually coming
from my heart and I mean it.
AUDIENCE: As a
speaker, what do you
do if somebody in
the audience is,
I want to say heckler,
but not really a heckler,
but trying to
attack you or trying
to divert you to a
different direction
and keep asking questions
that are not really relevant.
So how do you deal
with such situations?
BILL McGOWAN: I had a client in
the valley earlier this year,
and he was giving a keynote
at a big tech conference.
I forget in what country.
And there was one
part of his speech
that we knew could
touch a nerve.
And so what we did was I
heckled him in rehearsal.
And we planned what three or
four possible shout outs could
be and what our responses
would be to those.
But short of practicing,
it happens spontaneously
and you're not prepared
for it, what you want to do
is not look rattled by it.
I think what you want to give
the appearance of is being
welcoming of the conversation,
but just not right here.
So you could say
the person, what
you raise is a
totally valid point.
I'm more than happy to have
this conversation with you
after the presentation,
because this is something that
obviously matters
to you individually.
I'm speaking to the
general crowd now.
So come find me afterwards.
You don't want to just
slap it down and look
like this has
totally rattled me.
AUDIENCE: Can you suggest
some gracious ways
to handle someone who's
constantly interrupting?
Like say you've got a few points
that you need to get through
and they're kind
of asking questions
of the next few things
you're going to say.
What would be a gracious
way just to put them off
without looking like
it's rattling you?
Or what's a gracious
way to handle that?
BILL McGOWAN: And
this person you
obviously want to maintain
a good dynamic with.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BILL McGOWAN: Instead of
saying, would you stop,
would you butt out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Like a team member,
maybe on a smaller scale
where you're trying to
present a few key ideas--
BILL McGOWAN: I think
what you want to do--
and this is advice I
give to clients when
they have a potentially
confrontational situation
with a reporter-- and that
is don't pick a fight.
Don't immediately say
I'm getting to that,
and do something
that feels annoyed.
But you can say I love the
fact that you're really
eager to get the whole story,
and we have the whole story,
more than happy to take
any follow up questions.
But it's all in here,
so stay with me on this.
OK.
You almost want to
create the feeling
that you like the fact that
they're so into it that they
can't wait to find out about it.
You try to view it through
the positive prism.
Because when you slap
them down and make
it look like would you
please stop doing that,
it doesn't really help.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
We would all love to
have a coach like you
before our presentations,
but for us that
don't have coaches, what are
some tips that you could give
us that we could do for
just practicing, preparing,
anything?
BILL McGOWAN: Try not to
sit down at your computer
and write it out.
So if you need to
come up with a script,
I'd much rather you make
an outline on index cards.
And so make yourself
a structure.
And then take your
phone or your tablet
and prop it up and roll
video on yourself doing it.
OK?
And just organically
talk through what
you would say to the outline.
And if you want then
to go off of-- if you
want to have a text, like a
verbatim thing, what I'd rather
you do is take the
transcription of that video
and make that the basis
of your presentation.
Because what that will
be is a really accurate
written out version of how
we talk conversationally.
Most people, when they
sit down a computer,
unless they've written for TV or
radio, don't write for the ear.
They write for the eye.
And that usually makes it
hard to deliver the content
in a way that sounds
natural and organic.
So if you have the
time, see if you
can make this
transcription the basis,
and then start shaving it down.
Because obviously,
you're not going
to probably want to
use the whole thing.
And see if you can rehearse
it enough into your phone
so you can see how
you're coming across.
And see if you can whittle
it back to that outline form.
So you're never reading
big chunks of text
on the PowerPoint or-- we didn't
even talk about that today.
But I trust all of you--
try not to read your slides.
Try to use imagery
as much as possible.
Try to keep the information in
the data as sparse as humanly
possible.
But that would be
my major advice.
And use that as a
self critique tool.
And just think to yourself,
what are my big ideas?
What do I want these people
leaving the room thinking?
And am I teeing
up these big ideas
and putting them up on
that pedestal enough?
AUDIENCE: As a rule
of thumb, do you
offer any guidance about how
much somebody should present
for a certain type
of presentation?
So for a 30 minute presentation,
how many hours of prep time
do you recommend?
BILL McGOWAN: I think
it's somewhat individual.
But I think that it's more
important about not obsessively
rehearsing right up to
the minute you go on.
In fact, I think sometimes
in that last half
hour, 45 minutes, it'd be great
to take your mind off of it.
Sudoku, Words With Friends,
a crossword puzzle,
any mental game you
have that relaxes you,
I think that's a lot better
to do right before you go on.
Because I find when
you obsessively
concentrate on what you're going
to do when you go out there,
you can get kind of tight.
AUDIENCE: At the beginning
of the presentation,
you mentioned
sometimes people could
tend to sound very tight or
nervous in the beginning.
And then you mentioned
that breathing
is important to help with that.
I was wondering if
you could elaborate.
Because just recently, we had
a presentation and someone
seemed so nervous that I ended
up getting nervous for them.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL McGOWAN: I had a woman
introduce me not too long ago.
And see, Chris
was totally on it.
Was calm and cool.
But this woman who introduced
me, she had a piece of paper
with my bio on it.
And she got up in
front of the room
to introduce me on
good communication,
and her hands were shaking.
And you could not only
see the paper vibrating,
but you could hear it.
It was very hard to go on after
that and not acknowledge it.
I think you have to look at
other people doing things that
may work and may not work
and think, all right, well,
I like to look at the people
who are doing really well
and try to actually dissect
why they're effective.
And realize, oh wow, she
does that every time she
comes up to a big idea.
That that's not random.
That's actually intentional.
Let me try that out next time.
So it can be really
boring sitting
through other people's
presentations.
So if you took out
a pad and created
two columns for
yourself on the pad when
you watch other people,
effective and not effective,
and write down the
techniques you feel
are working for this person
and working against them,
and see if any of
those in the for column
are tactics and strategies
you could actually
experiment with yourself.
And that's, I think, how you
learn from good presenters.
So for instance,
I've seen somebody
in how they move around
the room be very strategic.
And what they do is
they move in transition,
but then when they
come to the big idea,
they stop before the big idea.
They're never giving
something of importance
when they're moving
and looking down.
That's going to mute the
impact of what you're saying.
So even how you move
around a stage matters.
And these are some
of the tips I think
you can pick up from
watching other people.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks a lot,
Bill, and thanks everyone.
BILL McGOWAN: Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]